[Music]  did you get my email about the no go  errands I cannot have people wandering  about middle of the night these things  always end up in a bloody mess welcome  to slaughterhouse this is the school  patent order at the top after bat in the  middle cleansing eyes  watch where you're looking then down at  the bottom what those weren't that's  fortunately I'm afraid mr. Prague it  will be unable to teach today or ever  again he died here anyway there's  something in the woods  whatever that o is a gateway Italy  straight down so how now who wants to  buy some drugs they just need half the  opera see  seat belts everyone  stop worrying what they're gonna do eat  you alive  [Music]